Laute.
Es ist unmöglich.
Oh.
Panorama.
Endlich mal wirklich einen Zehnenapplaus.
Wenn du willst, kann ich dir auch noch mal ein bisschen Zehnenapplaus geben.
Sobald du es verdient hast.
Mein Kopfhörer muss definitiv noch ein bisschen lauter werden,
damit ich hier mitspielen kann, weil ich bin ja schon alt und schwerhörig und
von daher brauche ich es mal mit ordentlich Wumm.
Nur weil jetzt die Musik ein bisschen laut war, noch ein bisschen mehr.
Ja.
Test 1, 2, 3, ist wie in einer Meta-Ebene.
Wo ist denn der Hörer-Meter?
Was? Ein paar Sachen, die sind nicht wie in einer Meta-Ebene.
Ja, wir können ja mal durchzählen.
Ja, hallo, willkommen bei der Freakshow. Es ist auch Vibesbild anwesend. Hallo.
Wir sind auf 31. Chaos Communication Kongress und das ist voll.
Wir begrüßen euch. Hallo, willkommen zur Freakshow.
Hallo, hallo, hallo.
Oh oh.
Oh Gott.
Man kann jetzt sehr souverän auf uns runterspucken.
Ja, ja, die sind alle gar nicht da.
Früher hast du aber auf so einem Kreuzschiff gearbeitet.
Ich war als Animator.
Naja, man muss ja auch noch Optionen haben, wenn man mit dem Podcasting nicht
mehr so gut läuft. So ist es.
Aber solange es noch Nachfrage gibt, machen wir das jetzt noch.
Und wir haben euch ja versprochen, dass wir dieses Jahr keine Sendung mehr machen. Edge.
Ich habe euch ja auch versprochen, dass ich nicht da bin.
Ja, genau. Edge. Und da bist du. Willst du kurz sagen, warum?
Technische Gründe. Ich bin auch nur virtuell hier. Also eigentlich bin ich in
Schweden. Ich gucke also jetzt sozusagen.
Ich arbeite mit Virtualisierung neuerdings und habe mich jetzt mal virtualisiert
und sitze jetzt hier virtuell rum.
Genau.
Gutes Hologramm, ne?
Ja, gutes Hologramm auf jeden Fall. Ja, das gibt mir die Gelegenheit,
dich gleich als erstes vorzustellen. Clemens ist bei uns heute mit dabei.
Ich sehe leider genau nichts, aber da sind Leute, ja.
Da sind irgendwo Leute, irgendwo hinter diesen Strahlen, hinter diesem Lichtmeer.
Denn wir sind ja hier im Sendezentrum heute, live auf dem 31.
Chaos Communication Kongress, der zu aller Überraschung wieder recht voll geworden ist.
Man kann es auch sehen, jetzt muss ich ordentlich rumsitzen, also nicht so Ja.
Nee, du musst schon ein bisschen Haltung annehmen, das ist schon Oh.
Stimmt.
Wichtig.
Das wird auch noch aufgezeichnet.
Und Jungs, die können auch unter den Tisch gucken, also.
Das sind ja ganz neue Dimensionen.
Ja, das ist ja eigentlich kein Mollton vor dem Tisch.
Naja, das ist alles sehr improvisiert hier.
Dann sind noch die Winkelkatzen hier mit dabei, die immer schön den Videostream
aufrechterhalten. Ja, ist wichtig, dass die alle wackeln. Und das Häkelschwein.
Und das Häkelschwein, genau.
Wir sollten uns mal der Häkelschwein-Oma nachher gedenken.
Ist die da?
Nee, die ist gestorben.
Ach, wirklich?
Echt jetzt.
Oh.
Es gibt ja der Sendung jetzt so einen Downer, ne?
Ja, ein bisschen.
Einen morbiden Häkelschwein-Touch.
Naja, auf jeden Fall, wir we salute you.
Oh, Häkelschwein-Oma. Du hast dem Internet viel Inspiration und Kraft gegeben. Und Häkelschweine.
Wikipedia meint, sie hat 15.000 von den Düngern gestrickt.
15.000.
Wer im Pippelkom hat ein Häkelschwein?
Mehrere. Ich habe ja mal ein Häkelschwein in der Schwerelosigkeit davon dann ziehen lassen.
Dieses hier?
In the Cloud.
Ist das dein?
Nein, keine Ahnung, wo das herkommt.
Und dann hat Samantha Cristoforetti, die jetzt gerade auf der ISS ist,
hat es mir wieder eingesammelt. Ist das nicht romantisch?
Während du Vomit Comet gespielt hast.
Während ich Vomit Comet gespielt habe, war schwer damit beschäftigt,
Haltung anzunehmen. Gar nicht so einfach.
Also Samantha hat es aus dem Strahl gerettet.
Ja, vor der kosmischen Strahlung. Roddy, zu meiner Rechten.
Hallo.
Ist auch dabei.
Das ist wirklich sehr ungewohnt.
Ja, das ist auch sehr gut, weil sonst hätten wir wieder kein Bier auf dem Tisch.
Du sorgst dich immer sehr um das Bier. Hast du das jetzt auch gekauft?
Ja. Äh, nein.
Okay, ne?
Das ist eine klare Aussage. Es ist eine Spende.
Ah, eine Spende.
Aber die hast du organisiert.
Ich bin mit dabei gewesen, Jan. Aber ich habe es nicht finanziert, ich habe es nur geholt.
Aber es ist irgendwie...
Premium-Bier. Hier ist überhaupt alles Premium.
Hier.
Bis auf... Da kommen wir vielleicht gleich noch zu.
Hier gibt es echt Nachteile gegenüber. Danke fürs Bier. Ich musste meine Pizza selber bezahlen.
Ja, Timme, wo ist das Eis?
Wie Fanta. Ja, keine Ahnung. Kein Eis, keine Fanta.
Keine Sendung.
Falls noch jemand eine Fanta hat. Dennis Morgf noch eine Fanta.
Keine Schoki. Ich bin auf Diät.
Keine Geschenke. Wie auch immer. Sehr offensichtlich, Dennis ist auch dabei.
Hat extra seine Schicht abgesagt. Toll.
Verschoben, verschoben.
Verschoben.
Ich muss doch nach.
Ja.
Das Vader-Mikrofon auch schon im Anschlag.
Ich bemühe mich.
Haben wir hier live auf, Nick? Oder wird das jetzt live auf die Hörer?
Ich meine, die hören das ja gar nicht aus dem Livestream, oder?
Also alle, die über den Download hören, die hören das wedern ja gar nicht.
Der Hörer das unbekannte Wesen. wir haben darüber keine Erkenntnisse.
Die sehen jetzt mal, dass ich das gar nicht bin, so sieht es aus.
Du bist ja immer fleißig auf dem Kongress. Du langweilst dich wahrscheinlich
sonst, oder? Wenn nichts zu tun hast.
Welke zu Hause wäre ja, was willst du machen, ist ja keiner da.
Ja, du kannst ja auch hier sein und nichts tun.
Nee, das geht nicht.
Geht nicht, ne?
Nee. Da müsste ich ja rumrennen, Vorträge gucken, das kann ich nicht.
Ich muss irgendwie was zu tun haben. Irgendwas.
Sollen aber auch ein paar interessante dabei sein, also so ist es nicht.
Ja, aber da ist ja wieder zu voll.
Okay.
Ich habe von jemanden gesehen, der saß oben im Saal 1, der war knackevoll,
der saß oben, so zweite oder dritte Reihe von oben und hat sich das im Stream angeguckt.
Ich habe dann auch geguckt, okay, da unten, da ist dann so ein kleiner Popel auf der Bühne.
Da hatten wir in diesem Runden im BCC, da hatten wir die Hinterzimmer in dieser
Lounge da oben, also diese Rundung, wie sie geht, und haben dann von da geguckt,
oder halt die Livestreams von den anderen, das war ganz okay,
wenn man so neben der Arbeit gucken kann, das ist ganz okay.
Ganz modern.
Ich würde ja jetzt auch Freakshow gucken, wenn ich hier nicht sitzen müsste.
Das machen jetzt die anderen alle. Die Stimme der Jugend, Huckel,
ergänzt das Bild. Hallo.
Die Stimme der Jugend. Das geht immer noch runter wie Öl.
Wie lange noch, Huckel?
Wie lange noch?
Wenn nicht zu Hause auch, wenn ihr das so mit Kopfhörer hört.
Klar, Dennis. Illusion ist alles. Genau.
Gibt uns übrigens auch mal Gelegenheit. es hat ja jetzt so ein bisschen was
wie sagt man, was Cerebrales, nee, was Leifiges, Ceremonienhaftes Cerebrales,
Spirituelles, ja, genau weil der Herr war ja deine Idee, ist eigentlich schon
geflohen, David wo bist du? David,
Los, aufstehen. Das ist David, der macht immer diese coolen Intros.
Zehn Applaus, Nummer zwei. Verdient.
Genau, deswegen habe ich nämlich hier auch gleich mal hier auf dem BIMAL auch
mal die anderen Menschen aufgebracht.
Wer leider nicht hier ist, ist der Florian, der überhaupt so diese ganze Intro-Welt
der Meta-Ebene und viele andere Podcasts mittlerweile auch bevölkert.
Und der Sven, der Graforama, ist ja nicht nur der Schöpfer des Freakshow-Logos,
sondern ganz nebenbei auch der Schöpfer des diesjährigen 31C3-Designs.
Hat er gemacht. Und wie ich finde,
wie ich finde, hat er das auch sehr gut gemacht, oder?
Ja, das passt.
Ich habe eine Designfrage.
Aber das ist nicht da.
Oder wie? Das ist doch der Ein- und Ausschalt-Button. Weil manchmal ist diese
Linie im Kreis mehr nach innen, manchmal mehr nach außen und manchmal genau 50-50.
Das hast du sehr gut erkannt.
Dennis hat ja nichts zu tun bei seinem Job und sitzt die ganze Zeit und startet
auf das Logo. Dann schneiden wir raus nachher.
Das ist ja sozusagen der Animationsspin bei diesem Logo. Das ist sozusagen ausgeht
von dem einen Ausschalter.
Und es gibt aber dann eben so dieses etwas fürstliche, eigentliche Logo,
wo das Ding da so ein bisschen raus steht.
Und dann gibt es auch noch die Variante, wo es weiter reingeht.
Die fürstliche Variante.
Naja, keine Ahnung, wie man das jetzt nennen soll. Haben wir eigentlich alle
dieselbe Kopfhörer-Lautstärke? Oder warum habt ihr mich jetzt gerade leiser gemacht?
Nee, bei mir ist immer noch genauso leise. Äh, genauso laut. Ich bin jetzt leiser.
Das ist genau wie in der Meta-Ebene.
Ja, bei der Meta-Ebene kann das ja jeder selber machen.
Ja, das stimmt.
We are not in Kansas anymore. So ist es.
Könnt ihr mir mal ein Bild schicken mit AirDrop hier von hier oben?
Das wird bestimmt funktionieren, Dennis. ist, das wird bestimmt funktionieren.
Das ist genauso wie Live-Demos hier von, hast du den Vortrag von Tobias gesehen?
Ja, halb.
Der kennt sich ja aus, der ist ja schon lange da und hat eine Live-Demo auf
dem Kongress gemacht und hat irgendwie Telefon in die Live-Kamera gelegt mit
der Telefonnummer drauf, also die, die er gerade anruft.
Was passiert wohl? Was passiert wohl?
Tolle Wurst. Das ist auch schon Steve Jobs passiert.
Stimmt.
Mit seinem Starbucks?
Nee, der wollte doch mal so ein WLAN-Feature demonstrieren. Was war das? iPhone? Irgendwas?
Und dann hatten alle die Journalisten ihre APs dabei, damit sie irgendwie Netz machen können.
Und dann hat er irgendwie zehn Minuten auf sie eingeredet, dass wenn sie das
jetzt nicht ausschalten, dass er da sehr... Ja, dass er halt so ist, wie man ihn so kennt.
Ihr macht irgendwas falsch. Der hier ist zu leise und der da ist...
You're doing it wrong.
Wer ein bisschen verwirrt ist, die Stimme die Stimmen, mit denen wir uns unterhalten.
Noch einmal klatschen für unsere Audio-Engel.
Genau, das ist nämlich das tolle Team hier.
Bevor wir nämlich hier vielleicht nochmal auf den Kongress kommen,
kommen wir vielleicht nochmal auf den Ort, wo wir gerade sind.
Also wir sind hier im Sendezentrum.
Diejenigen, die hier live sind, werden das schon irgendwie realisiert haben.
Leute, die jetzt am Strom hängen, fragen sich vielleicht noch.
Das ist ja so ein bisschen unsere Podcast-Lounge.
Hier wird viel gepodcastet den ganzen Tag oder auch Workshops gemacht,
also so eine Mischung aus Live-Podcasting und Workshops und gegen Abend wird es dann immer frivoler.
Und Claudia und Ralf, die da hinten sitzen,
die planen das jedes Mal mit mir gemeinsam und sind fleißig und ein großes Team
und flüchten danach und ein großes Team,
was dieses Jahr dazu gestoßen ist, war wieder ausgesprochen hilfreich nach unserem letzten Workshop.
Ja und Danksagung, Danksagung, Danksagung.
Also vor allen Dingen müsst ihr ja eigentlich alle auch hier dem Ralf nochmal,
besonderen Dank aussprechen, denn es trug sich nicht vor nicht allzu langer
Zeit zu, dass Tim noch mit Ableton aufnahm und es sein Recordinglimit von zwei
Stunden gab. Was ist denn das?
Mach mal.
Wurde uns gerade zugesteckt. Und dann musste man in der Aufnahme irgendwie nochmal
Rekord drücken oder sowas. Und wir haben ja gesagt, nimm nochmal Reaper.
Und der Tim meinte so, nee, geht nicht, geht nicht.
Und dann habe ich mich ein paar Mal lustig gemacht über den Tim,
dass er immer noch Ableton benutzt.
Und der Ralf, der hat sich ja eben um diese Röntgenschall, nee, wie heißt das?
Ultraschall-Edition, das Skin von Reaper gekümmert.
Und Tim ist ja tatsächlich konvertiert. und seitdem, muss man sagen,
in der Meta-Ebene ist Frieden eingekehrt, oder?
Ja, es gibt schon noch die eine oder andere Baustelle.
Aber im Vergleich zu vorher.
Ja, ich bin nicht unbelehrbar.
Es gab eben auch einen schönen Workshop für die Leute, die nicht auf diesen
Stühlen festgewachsen sind.
Heute Nachmittag um vier hat der Ralf das nochmal an die Zeit vorgestellt.
Also ja, alle unsere Zuhörer, wir haben hier ein bisschen strengere Sicherheitsauflagen
in dem Haus, weil wir sind ziemlich voll.
Deswegen alle Sicherheitsausgänge, alle Gehwege und vor allem wahrscheinlich
auch hier die Treppe nach oben nicht voll machen. Also da muss man durchgehen
können, sonst machen sie uns hier den Laden dicht.
Es geht wohl vor allem um die Rolltreppe. Also ihr müsst hier den Fluss,
der sich da so ergibt, der Flow, support the Flow.
Genau. Keinen Stau bilden lassen.
That escalated quickly.
Steht da unten.
Ja, Live-Show braucht auch einen schlechten Wort mit.
Ja, das ist schon.
Jetzt weiß ich gar nicht, wie ich weitermachen soll. Wo waren wir stehen geblieben?
Zehn Applaus für Ralf.
Das ist die große Live-Dankes-Benefiz-Gala der Freakshow.
Und Tim, wie viele Leute sind es hier so?
Wenn ich irgendjemanden sehen könnte, weiß ich nicht, paar hundert?
Genug.
Mehr als auf deinen Hörer-Meter draufpassen.
Ich habe einen Vorschlag, jeder spendet dann nachher einen Euro und dann wissen wir, wie viel.
Nee.
Das ist ein bisschen creepy jetzt. Das war total scheiße.
Tu mal zurück, Rolf.
Sollen wir nochmal anfangen?
Wir waren beim Design.
Ja, ursprünglich.
Ich habe schöne Implementationen davon gesehen.
Ich fand nur dieses Fürstliche.
Ich wollte auf, Dennis, der scharfsinnige Dennis, hat ja gesehen,
dass dieser Strich mal da, mal da ist.
Und wärst du auch auf der Eröffnung gewesen, wo du wahrscheinlich nicht warst?
Wann war die?
Heute.
Ich hätte sogar da sein können, aber ich war nicht.
Gab es ja das Logo sozusagen auch nochmal in so einer animierten Variante,
wo sich dann diese Dinger so auch als Einstellungsregler so rein und rausschieben.
den Ding, was Falky gebaut hat.
Ja, genau, die Dinger haben sich so gedreht und dann irgendwie auch den Sound
entsprechend moduliert. Das ist mehr so wie so ein Synthesizer.
So wie Pfeiter.
Sehr schön. Ich habe es noch nicht nachgeschlagen, aber ich vermute mal,
dass es irgendwie auf YouTube YouTube Du Röhre. Du Röhre Duo.
Im neuen Fernsehen.
Ich war ja, Weihnachten war ich ja bei meiner Familie.
Ach.
Und habe diverse Gespräche Ja, ich habe diverse Gespräche, also ich habe mich
bei meiner Familie so wie ein Alien gefühlt, wie noch nie vorher eigentlich,
weil bei verschiedenen Familientreffen ging es darum, dass man ja,
ob man denn die Aufnahme von dem einen Film noch gestartet hätte,
man den nach dem Familienessen noch sehen könnte und wann denn der und der Film
im Fernsehen läuft und ich saß so da.
Lineares Fernsehen?
So richtig what? Wenn ihr Kevin allein zu Hause sehen wollt,
ihr könnt das jetzt auf eurem Telefon machen, aufnehmen?
Da dachte ich gleich sofort an VHS-Kassetten und das Ganze und da dachte ich
irgendwie Generationskonflikt könnte...
Wie kriegst du denn eine VHS-Kassette in dein iPhone?
Also ich weiß nicht, wart ihr bei der Familie? Kennt ihr das,
wenn plötzlich eure Familie so technologisch komplett verbindungslos ist.
Meine Mom hat der MCD-Fernseher vor mir. Also ich hab da nicht mal einen.
Wer von euch hat eigentlich keinen Support gemacht in Weihnachten für seine Familie?
Ich verweigere das.
Die hat Windows, das mag ich nicht.
Ja, genau. Meine Schwester und meine Mutter sind jetzt alle schon auf Apple.
Meine Oma habe ich ein iPad gegeben, alles safe. Aber mein Vater hat immer noch
so einen Windows-Computer.
Der ist hartnäckig, XP.
Und er schafft es auch innerhalb eines Jahres, wo ich es immer zum Jahreswechsel
quasi neu aufgesetzt habe.
Wenn ich dann wiederkomme, ist es einfach die Virenschleuder-TM-like.
Also wie man sich Windows so vorstellt, im schlimmsten anzunehmenden Zustand. im GAU zu steigen.
Weihnachten, das sind halt die Leiden des Jesu. Ja, da geht man dann halt Kreuze
und muss dann halt AP Laserjets.
Ich habe ihm gesagt, ich mache es nicht mehr.
Tim, das geht auch außerhalb von Weihnachten. Wenn ich mal auf eine Party gehe
oder irgendeine Veranstaltung mit mehr als drei Leuten, die ich jetzt nicht
persönlich kenne und dann kommt ja irgendwann die Frage, was man so macht,
da darfst du nicht sagen, dass du irgendwas mit Computern tust.
Rosensüchten?
Es gibt so drei Berufe, wo du nicht sagen darfst, was du machst.
Arzt.
Arzt zum Beispiel.
Oh ja, also ich könnte es mal gucken.
Kannst du sagen, du bist Zahnarzt? Ah ja, wenn sie mal, ich hab hier ja gerade... Und,
Anwalt, Anwalt geht auch nicht. Darfst du auch nicht freiwillig sagen.
Nee, aber da gibt es Schlimmeres.
Und ich könnte Leuten tausendmal erzählen, dass sie früher so Rechenzentren
und so einen Quatsch gemacht haben.
Ich komme trotzdem mit ihrem Scheiß Windows XP und all so einen Scheiß,
weil du hast ja was mit Computern zu tun. Also musst du das können.
Wie kannst du das etwa nicht?
Windows XP? Genauso bin ich wie du.
Ich kann es, aber ich will es nicht.
Und mittlerweile hat das...
Wie schiebt das denn immer auf Altersdemenz?
Heute war das erste, dieses Weihnachten war das erste Weihnachten,
wo mein Vater auch nicht gefragt hat.
Also ich habe ihm das schon im Laufe des Jahres gesagt. It's over.
Der Long-Term-Support hat jetzt geendet, der Long-Term-Support.
Und jetzt musst du alleine zu sehen. Und wenn du meiner Empfehlung nicht folgst
und dir irgendwie ein Mac oder sowas kaufst, dann ist Ende im Gelände.
Kann er beim Bundestag anheuern. Die haben wir nochmal verlängert bei Microsoft. XP.
Du meinst, wenn der Lifetime-Support nicht so endet, endet er anders?
Ja. Es geht jetzt einem ganz natürlichen Decay entlegen, der wahrscheinlich
ganz schlimm enden wird.
Du musst den Faden wieder an dich reißen.
Ja, ich merke schon, dass du es an dich sterben.
Die Hälfte des Biagra-Spams, den ihr bekommt, ist vor allem im Rechner meines Vaters.
Oh Gott. Oh Mann.
Aber das Logo ist schön, ja.
Ja, ne?
Sehr fürstlich auch.
Wie kommst du jetzt von Viagra-Srem auf das Logo?
Gibt es doch eins, wo der Strich nach oben steht?
Ja, eben.
Ich kann ja mal gucken. Irgendwie leider ist dieser Beamer hier...
Hier ist kein Kongress-Logo. Logo-freie Zone. Da drüben auf dem Bildschirm.
Ansonsten pankt es aber überall. Die schönste Implementation,
die ich gestern gesehen habe, da hat gestern Nacht einer an seiner Nähmaschine
unten gepuzzelt, da beim Bällebad.
Nee oder Strickmaschine?
Nee, ich eine Nähmaschine. So eine mit so 16 Fäden und so und hat dann da schöne
Hoodies mit dem Logo behämmert.
Das macht er auch heute noch und wahrscheinlich auch noch am 31. morgens um drei.
Ja, das dauert immer so ein bisschen da, aber fand ich sehr schön.
Achso, ich hab ja hier jetzt keinen Ton. Ach!
Wolltest du jetzt die Themenliste...
We are not in the Meta-Ebene anymore.
Wolltest du die Themenliste von Alex vorlesen?
Ich kann das Scheißkabel da schon reinstecken, das Problem ist nur dein Brumms.
So, dann machen wir den Brummen aus.
Nein, nein, das hilft leider nix. So weit waren wir schon.
Oh ja, das Brumms.
Ah, ah, ah.
Jener Meta-Ebene.
Oh, das brummt bestialisch. Das können wir nicht lange machen,
aber ich dachte nur... Doch, trotzdem mal das...
Einfach erst mal einen YouTube-Clip abspielen. Egal, ob es brummt.
Hauptsache, der wirft mir jetzt nicht gleich Werbung hier irgendwie rein.
Das haben wir ja auch öfter.
Keine Ahnung, wie das geschnitten ist, ob das jetzt wirklich das Intro ist.
Ich habe jetzt nur das Opening gefunden.
Das sind 25 Minuten.
Das lädt auch nicht. Das ist auch mit Geralbine.
Das dürfte ein bisschen mehr sein.
Ist die Klimaanlage angegangen?
Aber es gab doch das Ding von Falk. Der hatte das vorher schon mal einzeln rumgepostet.
Ja.
Wo ist denn der Chat? Der Chat kann das doch mal raussuchen.
Der Chat?
Wo ist denn überhaupt der Chat?
Dem ist übrigens auch noch gar nicht applaudiert worden, dem Chat.
Nein, das stimmt. Und auch, ach übrigens, wo wir schon gerade da sind,
da hinten, der Tisch, der so leuchtet, da sitzen nämlich die Shownoter.
Nein.
Die wahrscheinlich gerade eine andere Podcast-Produktion.
Wuhu!
Ohne die Shownote wäre unser Podcast-Leben gar nicht möglich.
Wer hört denn die Freakshow zum ersten Mal?
Da hinten leuchtet ein Handy.
Ich habe eine Hand gesehen. Mutig.
Okay, ich kriege jetzt hier gerade YouTube-Klüsse.
Ja, wir sind immer so.
Wer hat alle gehört?
Oh, what?
Mehr als, okay.
Hier ist der Tiva.
Hier ist ja nur die Hälfte drauf auf dem Ding hier. Wo ist denn der Beamer da oben?
Das ist der Teaser. Das klang jetzt nicht so erbaulich, aber es sah hübsch aus.
Fürstlich.
Ja, fürstlich.
So, haben wir auch Themen eigentlich?
Wir sollten mal mehr über Mac reden. Ja, schönen Tag, der da war.
Wir sind ja jetzt hier auf dem Kongress. Das bietet ja schon die ein oder andere
Themenvorlage. Ich dachte nur, ich fange mal mit dem Design an. also vorne.
Und dann gab es...
Gehen wir durch bis zur Abschlussanstaltung.
Mich würde ja mal interessieren, du warst wann das letzte Mal auf dem Kongress?
Als er noch in Berlin war.
Jetzt den letzten, wo er in Berlin war?
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich doch... Ich war sogar mal im BCC. Ich habe immer nur
so Tagesbesuche sonst gemacht, weil ich mir einfach die Streams angeguckt habe.
Die sind halt qualitativ besser, als oben, hinten im Saal zu sitzen und unten
auf der Bühne so einen kleinen Problem zu beobachten.
Genau. Ja, kommt ja auch fast keiner mehr zum Kongress.
Ja, ist nicht voll.
Ja, noch nicht.
Das ist wohl anders vermutet.
Ja, ach.
Du hast anders vermutet.
Es reicht. Guck dir das an hier, die drängeln sich. Leiber, drücken aneinander, Schweiß.
Das ist wie in Stockholm beim Tanzen.
Ja. Du bist nicht da, aus technischen Gründen.
Doch, ich bin ja da, ich bin ja nur virtuell hier.
Achso, ja stimmt, das Hologramm. Das ist das Hologramm. Aber jetzt sag doch mal.
Deine Eindrücke.
Genau.
In zwei Sekunden.
Und nicht zu biestig sein.
Nö, biestig. Ich finde es sehr beeindruckend, was die Leute hier so anschleppen und machen und tun.
Also einfach der Aufwand, der getrieben wird, um hier Sachen aufzubauen,
hierher zu schleppen mit allen möglichen Verkehrsmitteln oder nicht,
weil ich da am Tag Null gesehen habe, wie die Leute hier angekommen sind, Sack und Pack und so.
Das finde ich schon, also die Dedication der Leute finde ich schon ganz cool,
dass die hier halt eben hinkommen und ihr Happening machen.
Und du hast ja sicherlich auch die Netzwerksituation ein bisschen genauer angeschaut.
Nee.
Interessiert den doch nicht. Hat er doch selber.
Du willst aber bei McDonalds auch nicht hinter die Tresen gehen.
Seit ich jetzt hier LTE habe.
Pro-Tipp für den Kongress. Du hast doch, wir hatten noch in einer Sendung so Tipps für den Kongress.
Ich bin ja auch die ganze Zeit auf LTE beim Kongress. Ich gehe nicht ins Netz.
Ich bin total auf LTE.
Gibt es da noch mehr von?
Ja, ja. Multisim?
Achso, es ist mit dem WLAN an sich, also ich weiß nicht ganz genau,
wie so eure Erfahrungen sind. Meine sind gemischt.
Also ich finde ja, das Nock hat es mit dem LTE dieses Jahr richtig gut hinbekommen.
Nein, nee, aber mein persönliches Paranoia-Level ist irgendwie...
Ich habe ein cleanes System auf einer externen Platte aufgesetzt.
Und du glaubst, dass LTE sicher ist?
Naja, naja.
Welchen Programm haben wir denn heute verpasst?
Nee, die kritischen habe ich tatsächlich besucht, aber naja.
Zum Beispiel den mit Tobias. Der hat ja gesagt, dass es alles braun ist,
faulig von innen und kaltig.
Also das heißt, ihr habt WLAN an und GSM aus.
Nee.
Also keine Beschwerden hier jetzt, ja?
Ich habe ja hier Dauer-VPN.
Das hat aber funktionale Gründe.
Ja.
Okay, also keiner will seine Geheimnisse preisgeben. Das haben wir schon verstanden.
Er ist live.
Nichtsdestotrotz war...
Also es gibt ein Netz. Ich hab da mal was draufgesteckt, hab da einen Router
mitgebracht, den draufgesteckt und mit ein bisschen gekabbelt hin und her mit
dem Knock-Kathletik dann auch Bits irgendwie und dann...
Hast du mal einen Bandbreitentest gemacht?
Oh, der ist schnuffig. Bandbreit ist nicht so das Thema hier.
Das ist halt eher das Problem, dass es relativ binär an- und ausgeht,
das Netz, jedenfalls gestern.
Hast du einen Chinesentest gemacht?
Chinesentest? Ne, habe ich jetzt nicht so geguckt. Deswegen haben wir ja einen Router mitgebracht.
Meinst du die Winkelkatzen oder was?
Ne, ne, ne, den Scanner. Also da irgendwas haben die Kollegen hier auch eingebaut.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob die die Access Points machen oder irgendwas.
Also wir wären hier nicht so zugearbt und so, wie man jetzt eigentlich erwarten würde.
Aus dem Alter sind wir raus.
ARP.
Das hatten wir früher.
Aber ansonsten, ich werde jetzt hier einen Teufel tun und das Netz irgendwie beurteilen.
Naja, weiß nicht, keine Ahnung. Vielleicht nur so zum Design oder irgendwas. Es gibt ein Netz.
Scannen mich, pingen mich, gib mir Hostnamen.
Ist eigentlich beim Netz irgendwas anders als letztes Jahr?
Ich bin auf LTE, keine Ahnung.
Es ist halt ein bisschen nackig.
Aber das will man ja so.
In der Download-Section sind jetzt auch BT-Sync-Schlüssel drin.
Da, wo die ganzen FDP-Server stehen.
Ach, echt?
Ja, gibt es auch BT-Sync-Schlüssel. Kommt man am BitTorrent synken.
Welcher Download-Section?
Da kann man ja gar nicht einzelne Files auswählen, oder?
Das ist wie früher bei der LAN-Party, weißt du, wo du so Computer gezockt hast
und dann war das bei euch auch so, zumindest bei mir war das so,
dann am Ende der LAN-Party, wenn schon alle so, ja,
ich kann die Cola nicht mehr halten, dann wurden noch so auf alle Rechner,
die Files, die man so ergattert hatte auf irgendwelchen FTP-Servern und irgendwie
so schnell ausgetauscht noch.
Und dann ist man nach Hause gekommen, hat so seinen Rechner gebootet und dann
hatte man plötzlich irgendwelche Files von irgendwelchen Leuten.
Und das war echt ganz cool.
What could possibly go wrong?
Ja, nee, ich habe tatsächlich Musik auf diese Art und Weise kennengelernt,
die ich sonst nicht gefunden hätte.
Welche denn? Das zeigt nicht.
Aber ich war noch Teenager und da durfte man sowas hören.
Ja.
Ja, ja. Die Stimme der Jugend.
Ach so, das muss ich gerade sagen.
Nee, hat's.
Nee, war schon von der Insel war das.
Dings hier.
Ja, genau.
Oasis.
Oh, vielleicht.
Ich muss sagen.
Das war kein Nein.
Kein Emino.
Ja, auch sicher, bestimmt. War einiges dabei auf jeden Fall.
Noch mit Jason zusammen.
Die Falschher-Sünden der Jugend.
Ja, sonstige Infrastruktur, also ich habe zum Beispiel genossen,
dass das so mit den Apps, auch wenn es vielleicht alles noch nicht perfekt ist,
aber es verbessert sich auf jeden Fall so.
Ein Problem ist mit den Apps. Das Lounge-Programm ist da nicht drin,
oder? Also zumindest bisher nicht.
Wer wissen will, was in der Lounge passiert und das kann ich nur sehr empfehlen, das zu erfahren.
Im Wiki, im Public-Wiki gibt es jetzt unter dem Raum Lounge,
Room-Lounge ist glaube ich der Pfad,
da gibt es wohl das kontinuierlich erweiterte Lounge-Programm und da sind wirklich,
also da sind Sachen drin, da will man hier gar nicht mehr sitzen,
sondern will direkt runter und feiern gehen. Also danach.
Ja.
Und weil das ist eben nicht in den Apps drin. Letztes Jahr war es im Fahrplan
drin, dieses Jahr ist es nicht drin, wer das Launch-Programm will und soll,
also ihr sollt das wollen, finde ich.
Es ist übrigens so, dass wenn man in der Lage ist, ein eine Google-Suche zu...
ein maschinenlesbares Quellformat für so Sachen und iCal wäre zum Beispiel eine denkbare.
Also wenn jemand diesen Plan in so einen Google-Kalender einhacken würde,
dann könnte Toto das zum Beispiel in seiner App noch einbinden.
Da sind wir nämlich gerade dran, das für das Sendezentrum noch mitzumachen.
Also insofern sind die Apps schon ein wenig vorbereitet.
Ich scrolle mal runter. Ist denn da wirklich ein Kalender?
Ah, ja, doch. Oh, da geht's los. Weiter, weiter runter. Weiter, weiter.
Guck mal, da gibt's das ja schon als iCal, dann könnte man's auch in die App gießen.
Toto.
Ah, ich hab irgendwo draufgeklickt. Entschuldigung.
Tim.
Sorry.
Ja, und morgen meine persönliche Empfehlung spielt ja Janina Rockt.
Ah, die hast du das letzte Mal schon. Hab ich schon geplagt.
Die guckt euch mal an. Das war wirklich letztes Jahr das Highlight für mich
in der Lounge. Die hat gerockt.
Schauen wir mal.
Ich glaube 21 Uhr morgen.
Wir schauen ja gerade.
Scrollt das etwa kontinuierlich über die Tage?
Nein.
Ist es wahr? Es geht immerhin bis...
Nicht über Kalender reden.
Doch. Das finde ich schon eine Leistung. Die haben tatsächlich geschafft,
hier ein View zu machen, wo mal der Tag bis 8 Uhr morgens geht.
Aber die spielt nicht morgen.
Ja, morgen Abend erst um 21 Uhr.
Blackberry Fields.
Aber wer sich so ein bisschen auskennt mit Musik, wird feststellen,
dass das hier schon ganz ordentlich ist.
Doch, am 28. sollte sie eigentlich... Zumindest hat sie es selber... Ach da, Nina rockt.
Nina rockt, ja, Nina heißt sie eigentlich. Aber dann, okay, sie wurde verschoben
auf 19 Uhr am dritten Tag.
Genau, so sieht es aus.
Merkt euch das. Wir sehen uns alle da.
Nina sings with her guitar.
Ja, war wirklich superlat. das Jahr. No pressure, Janina.
Das wird schon.
Keine Angst.
Du kriegst das bestimmt noch mal hin, die Nerds zu rocken.
Genau. So, Toto, falls du uns zuhörst, kannst du ja auch noch die Lounge mit ins Programm machen.
Und falls Toto nicht gehört, haben wir die Höhle.
Genau, wenn ihr ihn seht, antippen und dran erinnern. Didn't you read the memo?
Ähm.
Wir sehen ja eh nix.
Der eben war noch da.
Jetzt auf Twitter, Mr. Toto.
Das hätten wir auch nochmal einen schönen Szenenapplaus verpassen können.
Aber nein, nein.
Wir können ja auch seine Telefonnummer durchsagen.
Oder auf einen Beamer tun, das reicht schon.
Zum Party-Space sollte man vielleicht auch gleich noch was sagen.
Also nachdem da letztes Jahr ein enormer Aufwand getrieben wurde und es ganz
unglaublich aussah und irgendwie eine total abgefahrene Bar war und danach meinten so, oh Gott,
naja, 30 Jahre CCC, da kann man ja auch mal auf die Scheiße hauen und das werden
wir so nicht wieder hinkriegen haben wir im Wesentlichen das gleiche plus X,
wie ich finde the only way is up,
Ja, ohnehin nur.
Das kann ich jetzt nicht beurteilen.
Aber was letztes Jahr krass war, ich habe Leute getroffen am dritten Tag und
ich habe gesagt, wart ihr schon hier in der Lounge und so? Und die so,
Lounge? Da so, wo es Essen gibt und so?
Und ich so, ihr wart noch nicht in der Lounge? Wie Lounge?
Alter, das mit der Lounge ist auch wirklich, es gibt nämlich zwei Orte,
die alle konsistent als Lounge bezeichnen. Das eine ist unten und das andere ist oben.
Wer von euch war schon in der Lounge?
In welcher?
In der großen Party? Wer war noch nicht in der Party-Lounge?
Was? Einige.
Alle danach rüber gesprochen.
Wer weiß nicht, wo die Party-Lounge ist?
Oh Gott. Zu viele.
Okay, euer Hacker-Scavenger-Hand, es gibt ja die Hacker-Schnitzeljagd,
da muss auf jeden Fall der Punkt rein.
Find the Lounge.
Und bringt genug Energie mit, dass ihr die Escape-Velocity, um sie wieder zu
verlassen, auch noch, also ihr müsst so ein bisschen balancen.
Ihr solltet nicht reingehen, wenn ihr schon total ausgefahren seid,
so ah ja, okay, jetzt hol ich mir nochmal ein Bier aus der Lounge,
weil dann bleibt ihr in der Lounge.
Ihr müsst mit so einem gewissen Energiepegel rein, damit ihr dann nochmal ein
Orbit schwingen könnt um die Mittelinsel, um dann wieder auch irgendwann die
Austrittsgeschwindigkeit zu erreichen.
Hey Harkl, kannst du nicht noch ein bisschen mehr englische Waterine bringen?
Wie sagst du denn Escape? Fluchtgeschwindigkeit? Ja, Fluchtgeschwindigkeit.
Passt schon.
Aber es klingt so schön.
Escape Velocity. Ja, Escape Velocity ist ganz toll.
Rücksturz zur Erde.
War so ein Spiel auf dem Mac damals, eins der wenigen. Deswegen wollte ich Grafikdesigner
werden, weil es keine Spiele gab, sondern nur Grafikprogramme.
Ich denke aber erst über die Geschwindigkeit nach, mit der ich auf die Escape-Taste
gehauen bekomme, um irgendwas abzubrechen.
Geht einfach in die Lounge. Irgendwie kommt er da schon wieder raus.
Ich war schon drin. Da steht ja ein Schild, da steht ja Gute Halle 3.
Wenn ihr keine Container seht, seid ihr feilt.
Genau. Container und...
Oh, Schoki.
Schoki.
Oh Gott.
Live schmatzen.
Mit Sicherheitshinweis. Damit nichts fehlt.
Eine Python-Schokolade.
Ja, eine Python-Schokolade. Hier mit Werbung. Python Softwareverband e.V.
Ich schätze mal, das ist dann auch der Absender.
Reden wir überhaupt gut über Python?
Ja, ja. Wir reden nicht schlecht über Python.
Jetzt muss die Ruby-Community aber nachziehen.
Das ist für uns schon gut, wenn wir nicht schlecht über Python reden.
Ist das gut. Ja, mir gefällt Python auch immer besser.
Wir sollten mal mehr über Python reden. Python ist doch toll.
Komm.
Nee, danke.
Nur, dass du das einmal richtig abheißen musst.
Ja, mach ich mal.
Die ist aber schon so ein bisschen...
Weich.
Nee, also die war mal weicher.
Was sagt das über die Temperatur, die der Prozessor hat?
Schlechte Lagerung. Haut rein, wird bestimmt...
Also, das geht gar nicht.
Gleich flüssig.
Ich wollte was zur Party-Lounge, von der keiner weiß, wie sie heißt, sagen.
Die Lounge, deren Namen nicht genannt werden darf.
Genau.
Am besten Schatten legen.
Könnt ihr mir noch ein bisschen mehr Kopfhörer...
Ja, aber nur den Tim bitte, weil alle anderen sind schwerhörig.
Ja, ich bin schwerhörig, ich brauch das.
First rule of party lounge.
Ja.
Also da gibt es ja ein paar echt abgefahrene Installationen.
Ein Teil von Tim only war da unklar.
Ja,
es ist jetzt ein bisschen schwierig mit dem Durchzählen, weil wir jetzt auf einmal fünf sind.
Ich mache Oropax.
Soll ich mal gucken.
Wo ich hier draufstecke?
Ach so, weil die vorherigen Sendungen dann...
Also die Party-Lounge, Tim.
Die Party-Lounge.
Bleib doch mal beim Thema.
Ja, ich bleib beim Thema.
Die Frage ist, ob ihr bei meinem Thema bleiben würdet.
Nein, schaffst du nicht.
Aber ich kann länger.
Wir gehen dann einfach.
Du bist aber heute nicht am Steuerpult, ist dir schon klar.
Die Ente bleibt draußen.
Auf jeden Fall gibt es mehrere interessante Installationen. cool ist zum Beispiel,
dass diese ganze Lichtinstallation mit diesen Spiegeln und diesen wie sagt man
im Lichtdeutsch richtig?
Im Lichtdeutsch.
Diese Strahler.
Du willst nicht Laser sagen?
Nein, es sind ja auch keine Laser.
Geformte Lichtstrahler. Da gibt es so einen Ausdruck.
Spot?
Deutsch.
Achso.
Hier wird nur mit dem Kopf geschüttet. Scanner heißt das doch, oder?
Was denn jetzt mit dem Chat? Weiß nicht keiner aus dem Chat?
Ihr seid der Chat.
Ich meine jetzt gerade Scanner. Ich bin mir bisher gar nicht so sicher,
ob da wirklich jetzt auch Scanner hängen.
Wie auch immer auf jeden Fall. Es ist da gerichtetes Licht und es gibt Spiegelkugeln und es gibt Spiegel.
Und das Ganze ist so im Kreis, hängt das so von der Decke.
Und da hinten in der Ecke, das mag noch nicht jeder entdeckt haben,
gibt es so ein von Gungeon gebautes Kontrollpult mit so Drehreglern.
Und da kann man dann halt die Lichtrichtung steuern und die Spiegel auch steuern.
Also man kann sowohl das Licht steuern als auch die Spiegel wenn ich es richtig
verstanden habe und dann selber sozusagen die Lichtsituation in diesem Partyspace anpassen.
Was schon mal ganz cool ist. Und in den Containern gibt es ja dann auch noch so Kunst.
Kunst und Spiel.
Kunst und Spiel und Spielkunst. Ich habe nicht alles gesehen,
hinten ganz in der Ecke, da bin ich vorhin nicht mehr zugekommen.
Da gibt es auch noch irgendwas mit Planeten und so, das kann ich aber jetzt gerade nicht erklären.
Aber was wir zusammen gesehen haben, war hatte das eigentlich irgendeinen Namen?
Keine Ahnung, war bunt.
Mit Beamern auf Tische geleuchtet und dann sind da so...
Sequencer-Rädchen mit Licht und Schatten.
Genau, und wenn man da ein Bierdeckelchen auf den Lichtsensor drauf packt,
dann hört es auf zu spielen.
Damit kann man quasi so Multitrack die Musik, die da gerade spielt,
beeinflussen. Also wenn du einen Bierdeckel auf das Ding drauf legst,
was für den Beat zuständig ist, dann geht der Beat weg, etc.
Und wenn du mit der iPhone-Taschenlampe auf den Punkt drauf hältst,
dann für die Zeit, die du es drauf hältst, spielt es dann sozusagen.
Genau, es hat aber so eine Umdrehung quasi, so ein voller, wie sagt man, Takt? Loop?
Beat?
Loop. Loop.
Sample.
Sample? Na ja, auf jeden Fall kann man da irgendwie ordentlich mit rumspielen
und es ist irgendwie alles sehr hands-on.
Und in so einem anderen Container, fand ich auch sehr schick,
gibt es dann diesen Wassernebel, der so mit dem Ventilator nach oben geschossen wird.
Wassernebel klingt jetzt gerade sehr appealing.
Wie klingt das?
Wo wir hier so sitzen.
Sehr schöne deutsche Worte.
Ja, halt.
Ah, du schwitzt.
Nö.
Aber Wassernebel kommt da so hoch und dann ist dahinter ein Beamer,
wo eine Echtzeitsoftware die Grafik, die aus diesem Beamer quasi rausfällt,
steuert und das Ganze wiederum ist mit einer Kinect gekoppelt.
Das heißt, du kannst dann in diesem Wassernebel irgendwelche Bewegungen machen
und in diesem Wassernebel reinmalen.
Linien reinmalen, die dann so farbig so sind und in diesem Wassernebel aufstoben
und selber meandert das dann noch so vor sich hinten.
Hast du schon einen Joint geraucht?
Nee, aber ich stelle mir gerade die Kombination ganz interessant vor.
Fuck, ich habe was vergessen zu Hause.
Adapter?
So kann man das auch nennen.
Ich hatte so Kekse.
So einen Realitätsadapter hast du.
Tja.
Das fällt mir jetzt ein, wo du so fürstlich von diesem Wassernebel sprichst.
Das Wort hast du jetzt aber auch gefressen, oder? Dann teste ich mal die Schuppi.
Das gibt es alles in der tollen Lounge-Down.
Ja, und mehr.
In der Lounge, wo die Hälfte der Hörer noch nicht war.
Ich war nur oben bei den Kaffee-Nerds und hab gefühlt den längsten Kaffee meiner Zeit gekocht.
Den längsten?
Naja, es hat halt so lange gedauert. Erst anstehen und dann hier.
Aber da musste erst mal das Fahrrad angeworfen werden für die Kaffeemühle?
Nee, ich musste ja überhaupt erst mal Kaffeeboden aussuchen.
Ich muss überhaupt erst mal Kaffeebohnen ernten.
So aus 20 Sorten such mal eine Kaffeebohne aus.
Welche hast du genommen?
Weiß ich nicht mehr.
Irgendeine.
War lecker.
Hauptsache es knallt.
Du musst sagen, war interessant.
Und dann habe ich eine Einführung für diese Aeropress bekommen.
Ist ja auch ein interessantes Verfahren.
Ja.
Kann man machen.
Kam aber Kaffee raus.
Der Berliner sagt, konnte man trinken.
Oder war nicht mal meckern.
Der Berliner sagt, kann man nicht meckern.
Oder war nicht nur scheiße.
Obwohl, weißt du nicht, vielleicht hat er diesen Katzenkaffee ausgesucht,
der da hinten aus der Katze rauskommt.
Kommt der aus Äthiopien?
Nee, wo kam der das her? Der kam irgendwo aus Asien, ne?
Ja, ja.
Diese Katzen-Scheiße, die Leute für Kaffee halten.
Kupo, wie hieß denn das nochmal? Ich hab da mal einen Podcast gemacht.
Ich weiß.
Kopiluwak. Kopiluwak?
Da haben wir einen.
Also er schmeckte nicht nach Katze.
Und ihr seid sogar schneller als der Chat, weil der Chat hört ja den Stream
immer so mit 10 Sekunden Verzögerung oder 5 oder so, deswegen ihr seid hier Instant-Chat.
Demnächst bei der Meta-Ebene vorm Fenster.
Da träumst du von.
Auch im Sommer.
Benke rausstellen.
Ich meine, wir haben ja schon häufiger darüber gesprochen, ob wir denn nicht
mal hier unsere kleine Runde auch mal auf die Bühne bringen und.
Dann hätten wir vielleicht sogar Themen.
Dann hätten wir.
Vielleicht sogar Äonen von Jahren sprechen wir schon davon.
Genau. Ich war mir immer nicht so sicher, ob es auch Nachfrage gibt.
Da hier ist die Sendung noch nicht mal Freakshow, da hatten wir das Thema schon.
Das stimmt. Gäbe es denn Nachfrage?
Nein.
Ich sehe schon, da kommen wir nicht drum rum.
Sag doch, wir bänken von der Meta-Ebene.
Also wenn du mich fragst, das sollten wir lassen.
Das war nicht...
Das klang nicht so, als genau.
Also ich habe letztens, ich glaube sogar Jerry Seinfeld hat gesagt,
er macht immer genau das, was das Publikum, Also er macht genau nicht das,
was das Publikum will, weil sonst wären die ja im Showbusiness,
wenn sie wüssten, was richtig weh war, sozusagen.
Und er macht immer genau das Gegenteil, so als Gratenmesser quasi,
weil alle wollen, dass er nochmal so eine Reunion-Show, eine Wiedervereinigungs-Show,
Sendung macht und genau das macht er nicht.
Wer findet hier Seinfeld gut?
Wir trinken ein Bier nachher.
Wer ist alt genug Seinfeld?
Unsere Brüder noch.
Zu dritt ist ja auch nicht schwer.
Ich wollte nur meinen Geschmack testen. Ich finde das auch nicht gut.
Deswegen wollte ich mal gucken, ob alle noch so viel sind wie Huckel.
Aber anscheinend ja nicht.
Das sind alle deine Generation.
Wie? Aber Seinfeld ist doch alter Scheiße.
Ich würde sagen, wir schicken Huckel zurück zu Jugendhakt.
Naja, naja.
Du fängst doch mal ganz unten an.
Sicher.
Das Camp ist angekündigt worden.
Okay, müssen wir denn jetzt, wo es stattfindet?
Ja.
Ich wusste es auch schon vorher, aber ich durfte es nicht sagen.
Ja, kann ja jeder sagen.
Ich war sogar schon da.
Ja, waren wir ja vielleicht auch, wenn du mir auch sagen würdest.
Wo es ist.
Zeig Karte, da hast du die Mäste.
Zeig's allen. Wer von euch war noch nie auf einem Camp? Noch nie?
Was? Anders von wer war schon? ist ja deutlich Minderzahl.
Da war sogar ich schon.
Da geht noch einiges.
Und so Standardausrede? Keine Zeit gehabt, Urlaub mit Kindern, zu teuer, zu weit weg?
Kein Zelt.
Also, Jungs und Mädels, das ist alle vier Jahre.
Und ich kenne es aus meinem Freundeskreis, wo ich sage, kommt alle zum Camp, ist nur alle vier Jahre.
Dann, ich komme zum Camp, vielleicht zwei oder drei, komm, hinterher zeige ich
den Leuten die Bilder, Die Videos sind alle so, oh, geil, scheiße,
ich konnte nicht, aber nächstes Jahr. Nein, alle vier Jahre.
Und dann kommt dieses Gesicht, scheiße, vier Jahre.
Also, tut euch das nicht an, nächstes Jahr ist Camp.
Ist so wie hier, nur draußen. Sommer, Sonne, Mate, manchmal,
wenn sie nicht ausverkauft ist.
Es ist ein Hippie-Hacker-Festival-Outdoor. Nicht Indoor wie hier beim Kongress,
sondern Outdoor. Ihr müsst da hin.
Und Huckel würde sagen, da kann man fürstlich rauchen.
Mit Datenklos.
Und Zelt.
Und ihr könnt eure Kids auch mitbringen, also ist sehr familienfreundlich.
Ich zeige euch mal, wo das ist hier.
Strom, Internet, alle da.
Ja, Ziegelpark, Millenberg, waren wir doch alles schon. Pfff.
Hahaha. Kannst du mal rauszoomen, damit man mal so ein Gefühl hat,
ob das jetzt nun irgendwie in sonst wo ist oder in die Gegend.
Warum ist das nicht Google Earth und wo ist dein Space Tracker und überhaupt?
Zoom mal raus, damit man mal...
Da fahre ich mit meinem Fahrrad vom Land sind drüber, brauche gar kein Zelt.
Also bei dir zu Hause ist es nicht schneller.
Milkenberg, das ist bei Zedenik und bei, wie heißt der andere?
Gransee.
Gransee, genau.
Mach mal so lange, bis man Berlin sieht.
Das ist jetzt der kleine Popel da unten links, wo Google steht, da ist so Berlin.
Naja, das kommt jetzt gerade. Da ist Berlin.
Also im Norden, ja.
Ich muss erst bei dieses neue Google Maps ausschalten.
Man kann da auch mit dem Boot hinfahren. Die Leute, die da Spaß dran haben,
die haben nämlich einen kleinen Hafen dort.
Und ernsthaft, nee, ist kein Witz. Man kann wirklich die Havel da hoch und runter
schippern und da mit dem Boot hinfahren.
Hackers ohne Schipp.
Ja. Ja.
Alter.
Dieses Google Maps. Man. Suchen können sie ja gut, aber User-Interface.
Mann, Mann, Mann. Da macht man was mit. So, nochmal raus hier geflogen. Aus der Wallachai.
Und da ist es. Da ist man halt jetzt.
Das ist so eine Stunde nördlich von Berlin.
Ja, Stunde, wenn man gut unterwegs ist und kein Verkehr ist.
Anderthalb Stunden, wenn man es gemütlich macht. Je nachdem,
wo man startet natürlich.
Und das passt schon. Und da ist mehr Platz als beim letzten Camp.
Und zwar, ich schätze mal so ungefähr das Doppelte.
Ob das reichen wird, kann ich nicht sagen. Aber es ist auf jeden Fall nett da.
Also kann man wirklich nur empfehlen, wenn ihr Kongress toll findet, werdet ihr Camp lieben.
Wenn ihr Kongress liebt, werdet ihr Camp noch mehr mögen. Noch mehr lieben.
Und Tipp für die Vollprofis, man kommt nicht am ersten Tag.
Man kommt so ein paar Tage vorher, weil der Aufbau ist eigentlich immer am coolsten.
Hab heute schon gehört, eigentlich beginnt für manche Leute jetzt hier im Kopf
schon der Abbau, weil es ist ja alles getan.
Jetzt geht es nur noch abwärts eigentlich, weil steht ja alles.
Das sind die Modellbahner, oder? Die eigentlich nur bauen, aber nie das Ding fahren lassen.
Das habe ich vom Oberguru gehört.
Also beim Camp am ersten Tag kommen, heißt das Ding überhaupt nicht geschnallt
haben. Einen Tag vorher heißt gerade noch die Kurve gekriegt.
Man war schon mal dabei halt.
Ja.
zwei Tage vorher.
Respekt.
Das wird schon.
Und eine Woche vorher, der arbeitet da. Und das ist der Spaß an der Sache.
Ja, ich kann Dennis nur unterstützen. Das ist einfach, also so ein Ding aufbauen,
weil ich glaube, man kann sich auch überhaupt nicht klar machen,
was da an Infrastruktur aufgebaut wird.
Das ist ja hier beim Kongress ist das ja schon fett.
Aber auf dem Camp, ich weiß noch, beim ersten Camp, was war so die erste Aktion,
die wir da gemacht haben?
Ich habe ein Beispiel, super. Und zwar, da mussten ja Glasfaser verlegt werden.
Exakt.
Und dann haben wir überlegt, wie kriegen wir den Scheiß unter die Erde,
weil man will ja nicht drüber stolpern. Also da war ein Trecker,
da war irgendwie so eine fette Eisenstange.
Also die ran an den Trecker, rein in die Erde und geradeaus gefahren.
Ging natürlich nicht, weil die Eisenstange kam wieder hoch.
Also ihr Sechster, komm mal alle her. Zack, drei links, drei rechts raufgestellt auf die Eisenstange.
Dann ist der Trecker losgefahren und die Stange hat einmal komplett schön den Boden aufgerissen.
Gleich Kabel rein, dahinter ist die Erde wieder zusammengefallen und zack,
war der Kabel verlegt. Und so einen Spaß hat man da.
Treckerbahn.
Und lauter andere Sachen. Also es ist schon ein Abenteuerurlaub.
Also auf jeden Fall ist es so, wenn man an Tag 1 von der Veranstaltung kommt,
dann kann man diesen ganzen Spaß zum Beispiel nicht mehr haben.
Das stimmt auf jeden Fall.
Da ist schon alle da, da ist schon alle voll, die Kabel sind schon alle verlegt.
Man kommt sozusagen, es ist so pauschal Urlaub. Das macht nicht so Spaß.
Sondern man muss halt selber mitmachen.
Ja, erster Tag ist wie zu McDonalds gehen. Man will da richtig kochen, die Suppe ansetzen.
Schön alles ziehen lassen.
Klein schnippeln.
Verwandel doch mal das Mnemonik erster Tag in ein Datum.
Das ist der 13. August.
Das heißt, man will dann so ab 10. da langsam einen trollern, oder was?
Spätestens.
Und wo sind die besten Plätze? Belegt natürlich, wenn man zu spät kommt.
Deswegen muss man auch vorher kommen.
Da merkt man nämlich, oh scheiße, ich stehe mitten in der Sonne morgens.
Mein Zelt muss man auch darüber wandern. Wenn man an Tag 1 kommt,
dann kann man da nicht mehr wandern.
Oder weil so viele nicht beim Camp waren. Ein absoluter Mega-Pro-Trip.
Survival-Guide für das Camp.
Ach so Pro-Trip gesagt?
Pro-Trip.
Du hast doch wieder LTE genommen.
Wenn ihr euer Zelt aufstellt und so ein Örtchen für euer Zelt sucht,
sucht eins, wo die Erde eine was ist das, ist das Konkav oder Konvex.
Eine konvexe Form hat, gen Himmel.
Denn eventuell regnet es und wenn ihr in der entgegensetzten Form,
also in einer Kuhle sitzt, dann ist es nicht so cool.
Dann wäret ihr nicht die Ersten, die aufwachen und ein kleines Urstromtal in ihrem Zelt vorfinden.
Na, mit der richtigen Luftmatraße geht das aber.
Aber diese Erfahrung dürftest du aber jetzt auf den deutschen Camps kaum gemacht haben.
Also im zweiten Camp hat es doch mal, nee, an einem der Camps hat man einen Tag hat es geschüttet.
Holland. Holland heißt das.
In Holland regnet es mehr.
In Holland regnet es und obwohl die das halbe Land renagiert bekommen,
funktioniert das immer.
Aber Zelt ist auch nicht verpflichtend. Es gibt auch Leute, die kommen da so
mit Wohnwagen, Caravan, Datenklo, alle möglichen.
Aber Zelt ist eigentlich schon cooler.
Ich kann Feldbetten empfehlen.
Feldbetten, billig, gut zu transportieren. Passt.
Aber das Gute ist, da das ja dieses alte Ziegeleigelände ist,
dass es halt irgendwie ordentlich unterschottert, überhaupt dazu halt Brandenburger
Sand, also Regen zieht da weg und das ist irgendwie auch alles mit Autos befahrbar, top location.
Blühende Asphalt.
Schön gerade auch alles. Das passt schon. Nee, nee, nee, ist schon super.
Übrigens kein Witz, es gibt ein paar Kilometer weiter nördlich die Havel hoch,
nämlich bei Fürstenberg gibt es ein Hausbootverleih.
Und das überlege ich mir jetzt gerade, jetzt wo ich es sage. Ich habe nichts gesagt.
Aber da gibt es ja.
Also leider schon alle weg.
Seit gestern haben.
Die bieten da diese, diese auch für führerscheinlose Schiffsführer auch das
an, da kann man sich dann mal so ein Hausboot für 6, 7, 8, 9,
10 Leute vielleicht sogar besorgen.
In Brandenburg ist das mit dem Bootsführerschein etwas relaxter.
Ja, du darfst sogar inzwischen über die Mühre chippern.
Okay, ist aber, kann ich gleich dazu sagen, ich kann, bin mir nicht ganz sicher,
wie das da ist, mit unmittelbarem Zugang zum Gelände von Boot, also ist nicht so.
Da gehört ein kleiner, ein kleiner Yachthafen dazu. Da gehört ein Yachthafen dazu.
Aber ich kann dir nicht sagen, ob dieser Yachthafen für solche Experimente in dem Moment auch.
Das ist ein öffentlicher Yachthafen. Also du darfst dann da einfach da andockern.
Ja, aber wenn da halt Leute mit Mistgabeln stehen und Stinkbomben werfen.
Was ist dann?
Mit Ethernet-Peitschen.
Mehr schwänzigen LTE benutzen. Cut 5.
Mit Windows XP Exploits werfen.
Genau. Ja, ihr könnt hier schon irgendwie mit eurem Hausboot hin,
aber dann müsst ihr erst mal Druckertreiber installieren auf Windows 8.
Hausbootdriver.
R-Print-kompatibel. Ich sag dir, mein Weihnachten war auch schön.
Kleine Support-Session. Lass mal hören. Was war's denn?
Windows. los.
Was hast du denn an Weihnachten mit Windows zu tun? Warst du auch bei der Familie?
Schwiegereltern.
Da war so ein Drucker.
Der wollte nicht.
Der hatte sogar Airprint. Alles hätte so schön sein können. Aber sie haben halt
das Gerät zwar mit Ethernet genommen, aber nicht mit WLAN.
Aber in dem Raum, wo der Drucker stand, gab es gar kein Ethernet,
sondern da wird halt nur WLAN gemacht, weil macht man ja so.
Und das war halt so eine Mauer, da ging halt irgendwie gar nichts.
Also wurde der Drucker dann per USB, also der Netzwerkdrucker,
oder per USB an den Windows 8 Rechner angeschlossen, der dann irgend so ein
ominöses Sharing macht.
Und ich hatte mich schon so gewundert, dass der überhaupt auf dem Mac irgendwie
mal auch irgendwie manchmal zu sehen ist, aber irgendwie ging es dann halt dann doch wieder nicht.
Naja, da wurde dann halt erstmal im Internet und hier AirPrint Activator und
irgendwelche Access irgendwie alles installiert und am Ende wusstest du überhaupt
nicht. Man findet ja auch bei diesem Windows irgendwie gar nichts.
Also du suchst irgendwie nach AirPrint und alles, was du findest,
ist den Installer und den De-Installer, aber das Programm.
Aber wenn ich dich richtig verstehe, waren jetzt die Optionen Windows 8 oder
Hilti. Da ist doch die Wahl klar, oder?
Ja, habe ich dir auch gesagt, aber da waren die nicht so für.
Windows 8 oder Hilti.
Schön.
Die kommt auch bestimmt mit Druckertreiber.
Ja, also Camp, ihr wisst Bescheid.
Wer.
Nicht kommt, kriegt einen Eintrachtens-Mutti-Heft.
Fliegt aus dem Chat.
Das wird bestimmt cool da Und Ist ja auch so Die Camps haben sich ja bisher
auch immer gesteigert Das ist das fünfte jetzt?
Also das fünfte CCC-Camp. Was interessant ist, wir haben quasi jede Location
bisher zweimal bespielt.
Zweimal in Altlandsberg, zweimal jetzt in Finoford und jetzt halt da.
Mal gucken, wie es da läuft.
Und insofern ganz gut, als dass man immer wieder merkt, beim ersten Mal ist
das alles total aufregend, weil du musst halt überhaupt erstmal dieses Gelände
für dich urbar machen und musst überhaupt erstmal rausfinden,
was gibt's denn hier? wie das TCH.
Einschottern in diesem Fall.
Ja, aber muss man mal schauen, vielleicht arbeitet man da ja auch,
wenn da sowieso so viel Kilometer Seidenstraße gelegt wird, vielleicht hat man ja so Hochwege.
Highways.
Im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes sozusagen.
Können wir, ich meine, können wir dann nicht auch so das Futurama Rohrpostsystem,
also du weißt schon, du stellst dich rein und dann Also du.
Ach so, so eine human-sized Seidenstraße.
Das wär's doch eigentlich noch. Und dann kommst du in so ein Bällebad raus.
Da musst du dich aber vorher verpuppen.
Also ich meine, bei diesem Kongress wurde die Seidenstraße doch für Erprobungszwecke
ausgerufen. Ja, aber wie wär's denn mal jetzt?
Also Futurama, Rohrpost ist nicht so weit weg.
Funktioniert die denn eigentlich hier? Ich habe zwar nur die Rohre gesehen,
habe nicht ein einziges Ding durchzwischen gesehen.
Ich habe einen Splitten gesehen unten im Erdgeschoss vor der Kasse,
da hängt immer eins relativ durch. Ich dachte, das geht bestimmt noch nicht,
aber vorhin ist einer da durchgeeiert.
Also hier ist ja ein Rohr.
Relativ langsam, aber beleuchtet und so.
Schickt uns doch mal eine Kapsel vorbei.
Warum haben wir eigentlich keine Station in der Sendestadt?
Warum haben wir eigentlich keinen Endpunkt?
Es ist entschieden worden, eine limitierte Version des Wahnsinns zu machen,
der letztes Jahr abging aus Gründen.
Limitierte Version des Wahnsinns. Ist doch scheißegal.
Was ist denn das für ein Konzept?
Alter.
Kein Wahnsinn.
Ich habe es nicht beschlossen. Ich bin auch nicht jetzt aktiv dafür oder dagegen.
Tatsache ist, es sind halt nicht ganz so viele Kilometer Drainagerohr gekauft
worden, weil allein die Entsorgung dieses Drainagerohrs war auch nochmal so
eine logistische Aufgabe, die irgendwie keiner haben wollte.
Andererseits fürs Camp ist es schon eingepreist, dass das da eine größere Rolle spielt.
Eine Rolle.
Mehrere größere Rolle.
Jeder Besucher kriegt einfach beim Verlassen, also wer, sagen wir mal, am 31.
morgens so aus dieser Lounge rausfällt, der kriegt so als Andenken noch ein Stück Drainagerohr.
Laser gecuttet mit dem Logo drin.
Das wurde ja auch gemacht, aber das war einfach zu viel. Das waren ja,
was weiß ich, die anderen habe ich 10 Kilometer gekauft oder so.
10 Kilometer Drainagerohr.
Okay, dann kriegt jeder ein Met. Nee, reicht auch noch nicht. Einmal Ronkase.
Einmal Ronkase, einen abholen.
10 Kilometer Drainagerohr. Bauen sie eine Autobahn oder was?
Das würde aber reichen. Dann können wir so einen Einzelhändler da in Cedenik
anschließen auf dem Camp.
Schocki!
Achso, Schokolade, ja. Das geht ja auch. Bitte.
Was wollte ich gerade sagen?
Machen wir eigentlich eine Stunde oder zwei?
Achso, keine Ahnung, wüsste ich. Könnt ihr noch?
Die sitzen auch nicht im Licht.
21 Uhr ist irgendeine Live-Musik in der Lounge, glaube ich. Ja, da ist mal Live-Musik.
Können wir ja gleich einspielen.
Aber ohne Sänger steht da. Ich gucke mal gerade.
Ich hole euch mal aktuelle Lounge-Informationen auf den Schirm.
Vielleicht nochmal kurz zum Kongress. Ich habe mir jetzt auch noch nicht so
viel angeguckt, wie das immer so ist am ersten Tag.
Aber ich bin ja ein großer Freund der neuen Raumaufteilung dieses Jahr.
Ich weiß nicht, wiefern ihr das schon zur Kenntnis genommen habt.
Gar nicht.
Ja, I don't know the difference. Ja, du bist raus.
Ich glaube, du musst es erklären.
Ja, ich erkläre es gerne. Also ich weiß nicht, ob ich alles zusammengefasst bekomme.
Aber im Wesentlichen ist das Hackcenter um Saal 4 ergänzt worden,
wo ja zuletzt das Essen drin war.
Das habe ich gesehen.
Dafür gibt es jetzt eine Bar im Hackcenter und in diesem Saal 4 ist vor allem
ein schönes Ost-West-Konglomerat, nämlich Chaos West.
Das sind so, also Großpott, wie wir Berliner sagen würden, ja,
also dieser Bereich da halt.
Westlich halt.
Plus die Seabase, also Ost-West, genau, Rhein-Ruhr und dabei geht da irgendwie
bis Köln und ein bisschen auch nach Münsterland und so rein.
Gibt sich ja aus.
Wurde mir so erklärt. und Seabase halt und die haben sich da irgendwie schön
eingerichtet mit Flippern und Pipapo,
Und Flipper gibt es ja übrigens auch in diesem Kidspace. So nackte Flipper.
Also alte Flipper und so vertikal hingestellt.
Flipperporn. Genau. Kannst du ja von vorne...
Ja, aber man kann sie nicht spielen. Was soll denn das?
Ja, aber du kannst die mal analysieren.
Oh, das klingt spannend.
Na, ist ja halt... Du guckst ja auf Kabel und nicht auf Leiterbahnen.
Ach so.
Also alte Flipper. Stehst du ja noch mit so... Katsching, katsching,
katsching, katsching, katsching, katsching.
Solange mir nicht eine Metallkugel ins Gesicht fliegt.
Ja, naja. Das finde ich gut, auf jeden Fall. Okay, ansonsten weiß ich jetzt auch nicht.
Hat schon jemand die Ruby-Leute gefunden, weil dieses Jahr haben ja die Rails Girls.
Ja, ihr habt noch eine Schokolade offen.
Also ich bin ja Ruby-Programmierer ursprünglich, also zur größten Zeit meines
jugendlichen Geldverdienenden Daseins.
und ich habe ja auch da in der Ruby-Community schon öfters mal geworben,
dass die mal auch zum Kongress kommen sollen und dieses Jahr haben sie es tatsächlich
auch selbst organisiert geschafft und die Rails Girls sind da und der Ruby Berlin e.V.
mit all seinen... Ist jemand von den Ruby-Leuten hier? Nein?
Tumblebee ist programmiert, keiner mehr.
Die Jung der Fangruppe ist auch.
Ich habe sie auch noch nicht gesehen.
Ich habe es ja bei 5.0 oder so, da gab es neulich ein Update. Also, ist durch.
Ist durch.
Mein Bier ist auch durch hier. Ja, mein Bier ist auch durch.
Dein Bier ist auch durch. Da müssen wir jetzt aufhören.
Sendungsende.
Ah, da ist noch eins. Glück gehabt. Aber es ist zu.
Ja, musst du aufmachen.
Hier kommen die Per.
Tischkante.
Zähne.
Fump.
Vorführeffekt. Yes.
Zehn Applaus.
So, haben wir denn noch Themen eigentlich?
Wir hatten schon am Anfang keine.
Wir hatten nur welche.
Ist jetzt auch nicht wirklich was passiert seit letztem Mal, oder?
Weihnachten.
Ich fand ja, jetzt wo rausgekommen ist, dass Sony gar nicht gehackt wurde,
sondern dass es nur eine Marketingaktion war. Also das fand ich jetzt schon nochmal interessant.
Das ist jetzt rausgekommen.
Da haben wir noch gar nicht drüber geredet letztem Mal.
Doch. Ich habe erwähnt, dass Sony gehackt wurde.
Aber scheinbar ist das ja nur eine Marketingaktion, weil jetzt ist ja der Film
auf Streaming-Plattformen in kleinen Kinos und hat wahrscheinlich mehr Buzz bekommen.
Ach, die Gehaltszettel ihrer Vorstandsleute zu veröffentlichen ist eine Marketingaktion. Cool.
Weißt du, ob die echt sind? Ist da jetzt eine Webseite von Sony,
wo du deine Kreditkartendaten eingeben sollst, um den Film zu gucken?
Ja.
Die gerade gehackt wurden. Gute Idee.
Was kann da schon?
Blick around.
Ja, es gab da ja...
Habt ihr den Film schon gesehen?
Hat jemand den Torrent da?
Das Interview?
Da meldet sich sogar einer.
Mit Torrents.
Echt? Können wir mal eine Management Summary kriegen? Bicycle Mark,
haben wir eigentlich ein Management Summary Mikrofon?
Ja, da noch ein Management Summary Mikrofon. Kriegen wir ein Management Summary?
Wer war das? Wer hat den Film gesehen?
Nee, er hat nur gesagt, dass er ein Torrent da hat.
Bei gesehen ging mir auch eine Antwort.
Aber jetzt mal ehrlich, der Film, der wäre wahrscheinlich komplett an uns vorbeigegangen.
Ich weiß nicht, wie viele Hollywood-Filme, die neu rauskommen,
ihr so in aller Regelmäßigkeit checkt, aber der Film wäre komplett an mir vorbeigezogen.
Und jetzt mit diesem ganzen Bohei...
Alle wissen von diesem Film, das FBI, alle sind irgendwie hinterher und jetzt gibt es doch dieses.
Ja, aber was jetzt mal wirklich interessant ist, ist, dass jetzt im Prinzip
Hollywood das erste Mal dazu gezwungen, gebracht wurde, wie auch immer,
einen Film gleichzeitig online und im Kino zu releasen.
Das finden übrigens die kleinen Kinos, die sie als erstes entschlossen haben,
den Film doch zu zeigen, das finden die übrigens relativ scheiße.
Das wird sich aber erst noch zeigen, ob das jetzt wirklich ein Nachteil für
die ist, weil ich habe eher den Eindruck, man muss das natürlich im Kontext
des Gesamtbasis sehen, der da entstanden ist oder entstanden sein wird.
Trotz alledem wurde das ja so noch nicht gemacht, zumindest weiß ich nichts davon.
Noch nie wurde so ein virales Marketing.
Genau, dank Kim Jong-un.
Unser Sendungsgemäßer Urschleim, nämlich die komische Firma aus Kübertino, hat ja gesagt, so, nö.
Ja, die sind ja auch alle in Weihnachten.
Feige. Ne, die sind einfach feige.
Das kann auch sein. Ich meine, wer Weihnachten feiert.
Ist feige?
Ja, aber irgendwelche U2-Alben verschenken.
Ja.
Ja, genau.
Während in Seattle noch Windows 8 Druckertreiber installiert werden,
wird in Cupertino schon irgendwie der Weihnachtsbaum geschmückt.
Ich weiß auch nicht, was das soll da mit Apple. Sie sollten mal irgendwas anderes verschenken.
Aber, ah, noch eine News.
Na?
Die haben ja jetzt auch ihr Berlin-Brandenburg-Airport-Ding.
Wer?
Apple. Das UFO. Zwei Milliarden teurer und verzögert.
Echt?
Es geht bergab.
Hattest du doch ein bisschen Zeit zu Weihnachten, ne?
Mit Steve wäre das nicht passiert.
Ja, ich sag dir. Volkskrankheit der neuen Generation wird auch sein,
dass alle mit so einem Buckel irgendwie rumlaufen, weil irgendwie meine,
ist die Tochter von meiner Tante meine Nichte?
Wo oder er war? Weiter?
Wo oder er war Cousine?
Die Tochter deiner Tante?
Cousine? Der Chat nickt.
Ja, Cousine.
Während so meine Verwandtschaft älterer Generation also immer wieder die alten
Geschichten aufwärmt, was ja so zu Weihnachten üblich ist und auch eins der
Rituale ist, den Weihnachtsbaum zu kommentieren.
Ja, der ist ja sehr schön gerade, schöne Spitze und so, das sind immer so Gespräche.
Letztes Jahr war mehr Lametta.
Und die Omas erst.
Ne? Bei der einen kommt es auch schon ganz braun und so. Kennt ihr nicht?
Die richtig Alten, die sind schon an dem Lametta vorbei. Die erzählen sich nur
noch gegenseitig ihre Krankheiten.
Das ist ja besonders spannend. Da bin ich glücklicherweise noch nicht.
Auf jeden Fall hat meine, was auch immer, Cousine, saß eigentlich die ganze
Zeit mit Kopfhörern im Ohr und hat irgendwie auf ihrem iPhone rumgetippt und
saß aber auch die ganze Zeit so in perfekter Nerd-Haltung, muss man sagen.
Mein Proveke, Stuhl.
Ja, genau, Dennis' Logo und so weiter.
Ihr habt das Kunstwerk unten gesehen, da am Ausgang, musst du mal gucken.
Wie ist denn das mit deinen Kindern? Passt du da auf, dass die gerade sitzen,
wenn sie auf ihrem iPad 23 Stunden dödeln?
Also ich habe echt ein bisschen Sorge tatsächlich, weil die alle nur noch so da sitzen.
Kann dir nicht passieren, war okay.
Ich habe für mein Notebook zu Hause so einen kleinen Ständer,
das sitzt Das ist alles hier so auf.
Also ich habe mal gehört, dass wenn man gerade sitzt, muss die Oberkante vom
Bildschirm auf Augenhöhe sein.
Ja, so ist das bei mir.
Von sowas hört man immer wieder aus.
Aber bei diesen Telefonen und
iPads, da hast du das Ding auf dem Schoß und bist halt so die ganze Zeit.
Aber das ist die beste Erklärung für HealthKit.
Oberer Kante auf Augenhöhe, du machst es mal vor.
Für HealthKit?
Das ist die beste Erklärung für HealthKit, die ich bisher gehört habe.
Wie?
Naja, für irgendwas muss es ja gut sein. Und wenn es nur das gerade Sitzen ist.
Wie ist das mit deinen Kindern? Sitzen die gerade?
Klar.
Hätte ich jetzt auch gesagt.
Die sitzen wie Papa.
Tim fühlt sich jetzt gerade ganz schuldig und denkt, oh Gott,
sitzen sie ja zwar auch gerade krumm zur Haut?
Nee, er denkt gerade, oh Kinder, stimmt da.
Sind sie immer noch im Bällebad?
Ganz unten.
Zwischen den iPhones, den Verlorenen.
Die gehen nur auf Tauchfahrt, dann im Bällebad.
Tim hat dir gesagt.
Kinder, immer rein ins Bällebad und die iPhones unten einsammeln und alle zu mir bringen.
Es gab vorhin einen schönen Tweet. Dinge, die man unbedingt getan haben muss,
die ich noch nicht getan habe, nämlich ins Bällebad gehen, dort sein Telefon
verlieren, beim Suchen ein anderes finden.
Das ist doch mal los.
Das ist doch nicht deins hier.
Ich habe genug SIM-Karten gekauft.
Kriegst du immer wieder eingebucht, ne?
Hast du auch eine Fritzbox dabei eigentlich?
Seriously? Im Kofferraum. Ich bin ja wirklich sehr, sehr kurz entschlossen hergefahren
gestern und hatte aber den Kofferraum schon voll mit lauter Kram,
den ich in Berlin noch so eingesammelt hatte aus verschiedenen Packstationen und so,
weil ich eigentlich dachte, ich bring das mal auf meinen Landsitz in mein Labor.
Ah ja.
Labor, Labor, Labor.
Das ist die Tee-Küche.
Und deswegen habe ich reinzulich den Kofferraum voll mit lauter Equipment,
so Router und Deswegen hast du geguckt.
Ob dein Auto noch da ist.
Unter anderem auch eine Fritzbox. Ja, genau.
Alles klar. Also wer von euch First Level Fritzbox Support haben will.
Reichst du gleich weiter.
First Level.
Ja.
Jetzt haben wir nichts mehr zu sagen, oder?
Ich hab sogar zwei dabei.
Ach, wenn du mir noch ein Bier gibst, erzähl ich noch zwei Stunden was.
Ich hätte eine LTE-Fritzbox und eine VDSS.
Kannst du meins haben.
Nee, danke.
War nur mit.
Ja, aber was ist denn jetzt passiert in den anderthalb Wochen? Außer Windows Support.
Ich wüsste nicht.
Guck doch nochmal kurz auf die Themenliste der letzten Sendung,
ob uns da noch irgendwie so einfällt.
Oh, jetzt würde ja das Publikum unsere Themenliste sehen.
Nein, vom letzten Mal.
Niemals.
Niemals. Es muss auch noch Geheimnisse geben hier in der Freakshow,
wenn wir uns schon hier vor so eine Kamera setzen.
Ach, das ist eine Kamera?
Da hinten, der, der da winkt.
Sogar mit Kamerakind, guck mal.
So stand es nicht im Vertrag.
Wir könnten jetzt auch mal dem Kamerakind mal ein Beispiel spendieren.
Ein Beispiel, ein Beifall spendieren.
Ja.
Jetzt sag nur noch, dass das Video auch live gestreamt wird.
Wir haben noch ein technisches Thema.
Natürlich.
Deine Cousine, wie du so beschimpft hast, die hört bestimmt auch zu.
Ja, Apple hat uns ja Secret Updates versorgt.
Ja, das Erste. War der Baxel schlimm, ich habe nicht genau geguckt.
Man konnte ja nichts dagegen tun, ich wurde ja gezwungen. Bisher Digital Rave.
Was mit NTP?
Genau, irgendwie NTP war braun. Weißt du, was da genau braun war, Clemens?
Also NTP war überall braun.
Es wurde doch überall gepäst. Das Problem ist, dass es sich dabei auch wieder
um eine zwar sehr gehegte Software handelt, aber es ist halt eben auch so eine Monokultur.
Es gibt halt nicht so richtig viele Implementationen von dem Zeug.
Das heißt, die meisten Leute fahren halt eben den NTP.
Und die meisten sehen so aus wie OpenSSL oder was?
So ähnlich, ja. Und wenn der da natürlich eintritt, dann ist das natürlich böse
und da ja jeder abfiltet von sich aus anmacht.
Und der läuft halt so gut, weil der muss ja die Zeit stellen.
Der läuft halt so gut, weil der muss ja die Zeit stellen.
Jungs, wisst ihr was? Da drüben sind die Rubyisten, habe ich gerade über Twitter
gelesen, da wo Punkt RB steht.
Peinlich, peinlich. Ich bin mal den Rubyisten kurz rüber. Hallo,
warum kriegen wir keine Schoki und,
Aufkleber?
Wir müssen ja über Ruby reden.
Da muss halt noch ein bisschen Python-Schokolade essen.
Apropos Monokultur, ISC, die hat es ja heute auch getroffen oder gestern, weiß man nicht so genau.
Die ISC sind die Leute, die auch das Internet-Software-Konsortium,
die so alle möglichen so eine Software machen, die auch Bind und sowas machen,
denen haben sie jetzt auch irgendwie ihre WordPress-Seite aufgemacht.
Was jetzt auch so ein bisschen peinlich ist. Also diese ganze,
sag mal so Standard-Software, die so auf allen Kisten so drauf ist,
ist so dieses Jahr so mehr oder weniger gut zum Opfer gefallen.
Letztes Jahr war es bei Freebase schon mit dem NTP, weil bei Freebase,
der in einer Version, haben sie den NTP so konfiguriert, dass der halt nicht
nur sich mal ein Update holt, sondern auch einen Port offen hat die ganze Zeit.
und dann konntest du Replay-Attacken über den NTPD machen.
Und alle FreeBSD-Kisten, die so mit einer bestimmten Installation,
also es gibt so ein Image, was einen Typ mal zusammengeschraubt hat,
um halt Root ZFS-Boot schon auf Pre-FreeBSD 10 zu haben.
Und das haben halt relativ viele Leute benutzt. Und in diesem Image war halt
der NTPD so Default an und in dieser Konfiguration.
Aber als Körper konfiguriert auch.
Ja. Und da gab es dann halt auch diverse Abuse-Mails hier und da.
Aber jetzt fangen auch wieder andere Leute damit an. Also ähnlich wie bei dem
SSL, wo die Leute dann mal nach Jahrzehnten mal in den Code reingeguckt haben,
einmal schön gekübelt haben, angefangen haben, entweder Neuen zu schreiben oder
den mal auseinander zu fleddern.
Fangen jetzt auch Leute an, mal Alternativimplementationen von NTPD zu machen.
Das ist sowieso eine gute Idee. Man sollte Verfassungen auch alle 50 Jahre oder
so mal neu schreiben oder Audiosoftware oder alles eigentlich.
Ja, so eine Libre-Verfassung.
Man soll ja auch alle fünf Jahre seine Wohnung streichen oder irgendwie so ne?
Oder irgendwie so.
Oder saugen.
Ach. Aber alle fünf Jahre.
Kabel vom Boden aufheben.
Mal renovieren, tut ganz gut.
Oder überhaupt mal ein Review machen, weil du gerade sagst, das ist so Verfassung oder so.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das immer noch gibt. Vielleicht gibt es ja hier Australien-Fans oder sowas.
Aber das gab es dann mal vor ein paar Jahren, dass die so kleine Sachen,
wenn die die so haben, so wir machen jetzt hier mal ein Parkverbot irgendwo
hin, dann hat das eine Expiration-Date dran.
Ich habe da Parkverbote gesehen, die so gilt nicht von 8 bis 22 Uhr, sondern gilt vom 1.
Juli so und so bis zwei Jahre später.
Wer macht denn so ein Parkverbot? Und das machen die extra, damit sie sozusagen
reviewen müssen. Sonst expired it.
Jetzt gibt es hier Bonbon.
Der Schock von den Show Notes. Die schreiben uns nicht nur die Show Notes,
die geben uns auch noch Aufkleber und Bonbons.
Genau, die Show Notes sind nämlich mit viel zu vielen Aufklebern angereist,
habe ich so den Eindruck. Und?
Sehr kühles Logo.
Wer hat es gemacht? Das Van.
Das ist ja überall.
Ja, der ist überall. Gefühlt 50% der Podcast-Logos, die so in den letzten zwei
Jahren entstanden sind, kommt irgendwie alles aus seiner Maschine.
Der ist nämlich, könnt ihr mal klicken, graforama.de.
Also, ich weiß nicht, wenn man den mal zuschaut beim Design,
ist es wirklich unfassbar. Der ist so schnell.
Hast du dir das so vorgestellt? Man könnte ja vielleicht noch hier so ein bisschen,
also dehnt sich auch so ein bisschen Raum und Zeit so in dem Moment. Ja, also man sieht so,
mehrere Layer von irgendwie Photoshop Shop oder Illustrator oder beides.
Weiß nicht, das blendet so über.
Das geht so direkt in den Vertical Blanking Interrupt rein. Das ist unglaublich.
Nächstes Mal vorher nichts rauchen.
Hammer.
Oder mehr.
Zu viel LTE genommen. Nicht so viel LTE einatmen.
Okay, what else happened?
Nichts.
Ja, dann gehen wir jetzt nach Hause.
Wir gehen jetzt in die Lounge.
Trinken Biere und andere.
Wir können ja hier noch dem einen oder anderen ein Bier ausgeben.
Falscher Podcast.
Ja, man muss ja auch mal was zurückgeben.
Genau, man muss ja mal deine ganzen Flatterklicks auch mal irgendwo anbringen.
Genau, Bier.
Ein Hörerbier.
Das habe ich jetzt nicht gesagt, oder?
Also das machst du, wir schauen zu.
Wir verteilen Sticker.
Du kriegst ja eh die ganze Flatterkohle.
Die Regie muss jetzt langsam mal.
Die Schleife einblenden.
Damit wir auch wissen, dass es langsam zu Ende geht. Und nicht nur wir, auch alle anderen.
Wenn wir jetzt so eine extra Sonderspecial inhaltslose Freakshow gemacht haben,
wann ist denn die nächste?
Regulär oder schieben wir die jetzt eine Woche raus?
Die wissen wollen, ob wir wirklich die ganze Zeit nur Scheiß labern.
Kann ich dir sagen. Nächstes Jahr.
Es ist doch schon dünner geworden hier, oder?
Nein.
Nur die Luft.
Aber habt ihr gesehen, wir wurden eingekesselt. Also hier stehen die ganzen
orangen Männchen da. Und die passen auf, dass hier die chaotische Masse hier nicht...
Dass keine Hörer rausliegen.
Die lassen keinen mehr rein.
Raus.
So, die Schleife bitte.
Ja genau, also ich denke mal, wir machen am 11. Ne, Quatsch.
Ne, schon langsam einfaden.
11. ist Sonntag.
Ach dumm, er muss das machen.
Film mal, hast du gehört?
Du musst klicken.
Moment, da kriegt der erst wieder den Brum.
Was muss ich?
Du musst die Schleife einfaden.
Wieso, ich hab das doch vorhin extra in die Treppe gelückt. Aber dann brummt
es doch wieder. Na gib her, komm, komm, komm. So.
Präzzt, Präzzt, Präzzt.
Wenn du drückst, dann zieht er den Regler runter.
Lass mich doch erstmal tippen.
Nein, das geht aber nicht. Du darfst den Rechner nicht berühren, sonst kommt es.
Geh weg.
Nur das Plastik.
Ja, geh weg.
Pass mein Computer nicht an.
Nur das Plastik.
Du willst nämlich die Brumm schleifen hier.
Du sagst es sonst immer Plaste.
Der Burgunen im Mittag.
So ist es.
I break together.
Muss ich ihm erstmal wieder diesen OS-10-Drops-Lutsch-Scheiß-Dreck anschauen.
Der hat eins Ball.
Da waren noch ernsthaft interessierte Coder fürs Displayhund.
Ich bin bis zwei an der Kasse.
Ich habe vielleicht nicht so richtig Dauerzeit, aber wenn wer da noch Infos
braucht, dann soll er vorbeikommen.
Ah, dein Display ist hier. Das haben wir letztes Mal angekündigt.
Steht am Eingang.
Ja, er musste sich erstmal meinen Dingsbums-Icon-Manager-Scheißdreck neu starten.
Und den Drucker-Treiber installieren.
Und er ist so unorganisiert, er braucht es. Wir könnten jetzt, das.
Was Frank und Fefe letztes Jahr gemacht haben, können wir jetzt hier ein kleiner
mal machen mit der Facepalm. Die haben in Saal 1,
Facepalmieren lassen.
Das ist doch genau das Richtige für den Audio-Podcast. Das machen wir alle mal Facepalmieren.
Aber laut, bitte.
Aber genau, mit mehr Geräusen.
Genau, weil jetzt ist es hier schlussend.
Eins, zwei, drei.
Ich mach nicht mit.
Schon wieder vorbei. Das war's! Witzschau!
Witzschau!
Witzschau! Witzschau!
Witzschau! Witzschau! Witzschau! Witzschau! Witzschau!
Witzschau!